micki road in do you ever read the terms
and conditions for things that you use
no absolutely not I don't know if
anytime that I've read the terms of and
conditions for anything that that I've
used software apps whatever I think that
there are some terms and conditions
which are sort of jokes because they
know that nobody reads it now where I do
look more closely at what I'm signing
would be like for example when I sign a
car lease I actually will look through
the provisions when I sign an office
lease in addition to having our lawyer
look it over I also look it over really
closely but I don't think that's really
the the gist of the question I think the
question is asking more about like even
when we download an app onto your phone
and there's ten pages of terms and
conditions and who knows what the hell
you're agreeing to I I know that I'm an
advocate of privacy and of responsible
corporate behavior and all this stuff
I'm kind of part of the problem if I
have hazard Li just scroll through and
accept whatever it is that an app
manufacturer or software maker is giving
me right yeah how how legally binding is
some of that stuff to like if you
upgrade your iTunes yeah
and it's ten pages that no one's going
to go through and it turns out there's
some crazy provision in there that you
agreed to can they hold you accountable
for that I don't think so I think you
can get away with it the so okay I've
talked to lawyers about you know how
when you go when you do something like a
go-karting or riding a horse or whatever
okay yeah there's usually signs that say
you're here under your own risk at your
own risk
this way the liability you're waiving
liability this is risky behavior you
might sign off on something even if you
end up getting thrown off of a horse you
can still get you can still sue the
horse riding place if your go-kart
explodes in a fiery disaster and you get
burned badly you can still sue the place
will say well listen we had this waiver
or whatever and basically the idea is to
show that they made an effort to inform
you of the risks but that doesn't
exculpate them of liability if they were
negligent so I think that the idea would
be even if you ignore the terms and
conditions sign off on it
whatever that doesn't give the company
unlimited license to do absolutely
whatever they want particularly if it
breaks some kind of law they can say the
person agreed to it but they might still
have done something that's against the
law so I think it's not 100 percent cut
and dry but the idea is they made an
effort to tell you upfront how they were
gonna handle your data or whatever else
and if you proceed at that point and
opted not to read what it is that you're
signing that's sort of your fault and
not theirs but again it's not just a
blanket they can do whatever they want
just because they put it in the terms
and conditions yeah that makes sense
it'll help them in court yeah have you
ever heard of like cash prizes being
offered and they're hidden in the middle
of terms and service agreements oh and
it is like go weeks before someone
claims that if you like in some
provision it might say if you send an
email to such-and-such actually and
nobody reads it and they know that
nobody reads the stuff because nobody
claims the prize for like months or
years or even ever that's what yeah I
this is not something I think a lot
about I have to admit I don't know how
much exposure I have to companies doing
really horrible things because I just
scroll to the bottom of the turns and
terms and conditions without ever
reading it I genuinely don't know but I
don't I'm not proud of the fact that I
don't do it but it's one of those things
that's deliberately set up so that
people don't do it because it
essentially makes your life impossible
if you're gonna if every app program and
whatever that you use you're gonna read
the entire thing and arguably it's gonna
be written in a way that the layperson
won't fully understand why not get a
lawyer to look at the terms and
conditions before you update your iPhone
software or whatever it makes life
impossible project we speak if you're
going to do that might as well just not
use any technology you're hindering
yourself basically in the same way for
sure we've got a great bonus show for
you today keep the questions coming sign
up for the bonus show by becoming a
member at david pakman.com slash
membership we're becoming a patron for
at least five bucks a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
today's program is sponsored in part by
Shaker and spoon the monthly craft
cocktail subscription box that delivers
a craft cocktail experience directly to
your front door every month they will
send you the ingredients for three
completely new original recipes and
for 12 total cocktails should last you
the whole month I sampled shaker and
spoons death by gin box which gave me
the ingredients for three gin based
drinks my favorite being the above a
persimmon drink you also get to choose
whichever brand of spirit you want I
chose a particularly dry gin for my
death by gin box and you also don't need
to have someone who's 21 home to sign
for the delivery yet another advantage
of being able to choose your own brand
of spirit but it's the other ingredients
that are really what's special about
shaker and spoon and it's also great
that you can continue to support your
local shop even when using the great
shaker and spoon service and for a
limited time you can get $20 off by
going to shaker and spoon calm slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link in the description right
underneath this video for you to use